notre invité politique de la matinale ce
matin nous recevons georges cusm anneaux
vici les présidents de la république
souveraine georges kiejman au beach
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
dans la matinale de rtl france alors
vous êtes président de la république
deux républiques souveraines partisans à
d'une france souveraine dans sa
politique intérieure mais aussi
extérieure alors depuis le début de la
crise sanitaire
la question du souverainisme et les
revenus sains au centre des débats
comment est ce que vous vous le
comprenez et bonjour d'abord mais je le
comprends comme la plupart des français
l'ont compris ils ont constaté au
travers de cette crise grave
d'abord sanitaire est maintenant
économique que la france n'est n'est pas
doté de toute une série de moyens qui
lui permettrait de résister par elle
même par exemple à une pandémie on l'a
vu avec les masques on a découvert avec
les respirateurs on le voit maintenant
avec les vaccins
on voit qu'on a c'est peu qu'on ait
pieds poings liés face aux grandes
entreprises pharmaceutiques et on voit
bien que la manière dont était organisée
l'état la manière dont organisé
l'économie ne convient pas à des moments
de crise et donc retour de la
souveraineté être en mesure soit même de
produire des masques des respirateurs
des médicaments des vaccins
c'est pour ça que même le président de
la république française mais chez menu
macro est obligé d'en réutiliser le
terme souveraineté était très mal
connoté avant la crise alors parra mais
justement les figures qu'ils défendent à
la souveraineté de la france il y en a
une c'est arnaud montebourg inquiets est
revenu sur le devant de la scène ces
dernières semaines en revanche lui il
s'est dit contre le fric cité cela fait
réagir notamment le président des
patriotes regarder puis on vous entend
non il ya d'autres méthodes possibles
je ne crois pas l'utilité d'un freak
site face à la récession historique
la seule solution est de sortir le plus
vite possible de l'union européenne de
l'euro et de toutes les tutelles
supranationale la france souveraine
contre le démantèlement oligarchique du
pays
refuser le fric site s'est refusé de
donner un avenir à la france
alors pour vous une france plus
souveraine est ce que c'est une france
qui sort de l'union européenne bien
évidemment on ne peut pas continuer avec
cette union européenne là c'est à dire
une union européenne qui favorise la
finance les multinationales et les
banques au détriment des peuples
d'ailleurs les peuples d'europe l'ont
dit à chaque fois démocratiquement quand
on a fait un référendum que ce soit en
france en 2005 en bretagne avec le break
site en italie en irlande en grèce
à chaque fois ils ont dit non nous ne
voulons pas de cette europe là et on
voit bien qu'elle a des effets délétères
ça a été dit par énormément économistes
1 qui intervient beaucoup sur votre
chaîne jacques sapir mais aussi monsieur
chimiques ce que l'euro nuit à la
compétitivité de la france monsieur
chevénement montrer moult fois que cet
euro à contribuer à détruire l'industrie
française italienne et espagnole donc
bien évidemment on ne peut pas continuer
avec cette union européenne là si on a à
coeur de défendre des intérêts des
français alors qu'est l'europe pour vous
ce sera quelques lots rome l'europe des
nations et charisteas arrosée mais oui
par exemple l'europe des nations
défendue par le général de gaulle et et
c'est là qu'on a accumulé
d'incompréhension sur le fric site
le terme est utilisé par monsieur
asselineau est hyper depuis un certain
temps et il se résume à une formule
magique qui est l'application de
l'article 50 du traité de lisbonne
et voilà par un effet magique tout se
passerait bien en fait les choses sont
extrêmement compliqué je pense que les
propos d'arnaud montebourg font
référence à cercler les ça a été
construit de cette manière le l'union
européenne nos entreprises nos grandes
entreprises ont été mutualisés avec des
entreprises européennes
nous nous sommes supprimer des moyens
notre souveraineté ce ne sont pas des
choses qui soient conquérants en un
instant donc il faut ce sont des choses
qui se font en avançant qu'il faut poser
et je crois que mon amour le fait aussi
suis pas tout à fait certain de son
programme est en tout cas une pause qui
doit y avoir des désobéissances à toute
une série de choses qui bien évidemment
implique un affrontement est un combat
face face à bruxelles
alors il a dit me semble tourner
travailleurs détachés par exemple où le
respect de certaines normes écologiques
qui sont meilleurs en france que dans ce
cas connu en peine alors en tout cas on
voit que cette question de souveraineté
finalement elle rassembla au delà des
partis politiques par exemple numéro 2
de l'est républicain guillaume pelletier
lui il avait relevé début janvier des
points communs avec arnaud montebourg 1
sur la souveraineté face à la
mobilisation
à propos de ce clivage gauche droite
voilà ce qu'on a dit hier olivier faure
le premier secrétaire du parti
socialiste
le dépassement du clivage gauche droite
c'est ce qu'a fait le président de la
république en expliquant qu'au fond on
pouvait être et de droite et de gauche
et du centre
à force il est où le choix le choix se
reportent sur les extrêmes alors est-ce
que les dépassements que ti l'image
bénéficie aux extrêmes comme le dit
olivier faur selon vous au contraire et
bien c'est la question de la
souveraineté contre le mondialisme et de
différents partis politiques ceux qui
sont souverains peuvent se retrouver
aujourd'hui
oui je pense que monsieur faure raison
il est l'héritier pardon que monsieur
fort à tort il est l'héritier d'un parti
dit socialiste qui a contribué à casser
les éléments de souveraineté de la
france le les services publics et bien
évidemment qu'il se trouve empêtré par
ce café emmanuel macron emmanuel macron
a proposé un bloc politique où on va
retrouver les gens qui préfèrent le
capital plutôt que le travail la la la
mondialisation plutôt que la
souveraineté multiculturalisme plutôt
que la laïcité est bien et dans ce bloc
se retrouve des gens qui étaient de
gauche de droite et bien nous pensons
qu'il peut y avoir un bloc qui renvoie à
un moment glorieux de notre histoire de
france qui est le conseil national de la
résistance se sont réunis des gens qui
avaient des gaullistes aux communistes
où on va défendre
la souveraineté plutôt qu'à
mondialisation le travail plutôt que le
capital la laïcité plutôt que le
multiculturalisme et défendre les
services publics et les capacités en
propre de l'état de protéger ses
citoyens et je crois que c'est là que va
se faire que se fera l'affrontement au
delà du clivage fictionnel gauche droite
tels qu'ils étaient entendus jusqu'à
maintenant dans les médias alors il ya
aussi la question de la défense vous
avez été vous conseiller défense de jean
luc mélenchon est la cour de justice de
l'union européenne pourrait contraindre
la france à appliquer à nos soldats les
principes du droit du travail européen
est ce que cela est bien ça vous
inquiète
oui comme toutes les directives pondu
par bruxelles mais qui ne sont pas
nécessairement conformité avec ce dont
nous avons besoin
peut-être que tous ceux qui font ce
genre de réglementation pour un peu
d'être envoyé à eux aussi plus de
soldats pour combattre le terrorisme au
sahel qu'ils ne le font actuellement
plutôt que nous envoyer des directives
par contre il ya une chose qui est qui
est tout à fait légitime c'est que nos
soldats est également une représentation
syndicale
qu'ils soient qu'ils soient encadrés
bien évidemment qu'on va faire grève
comme on le veut quand on est militaire
mais qui est une représentation
syndicale ce qui malheureusement fait
défaut aux militaires français alors
dans l'actualité également par les
militaires mais le bouddha sécurité
c'est le coup d'envoi ce lundi du grand
débat sur la police cette fois
et hier le ministre de l'intérieur était
aux côtés des policiers dans les
yvelines pour faire respecter le
couvre-feu écoutez le il ya eu une
augmentation des contrôles depuis de 30%
ce samedi et cela continuera dans les
jours à venir
les français doivent savoir qu après 18
heures ils ont beaucoup de chance de se
faire contrôler et donc verbaliser hier
il y a eu 65 mille contrôles qui ont été
effectués pour quasiment 6000
verbalisation une opération charme à la
veille du beau et de sécurité selon vous
si c'est ça charmant pas la même
définition de lieu de charme
non surtout ce qui est très rare dit que
c'est que c'est la méthode emmanuel
macron qui à nouveau appliqué sur un
problème réel
il y a des problèmes de sécurité en
france il y a un malaise policier vous
l'avez rappelé dans votre reportage
précédemment qui s'est manifestée par la
colère policière est ce que fait manuel
matheron mais c'est ce qu'il a fait
avant avec tous les sujets qui
intéressent les français ça a été les
états généraux de l'alimentaire de
l'alimentation qui au bout de 20 ans de
discussions doit accoucher de rien ce
n'est un avantage donné aux à la grande
distribution
ça a été les cahiers de doléances pour
les jets jaune si vous souvenez
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
cahiers de doléances après le mouvement
des gilet jaune et le grand débat on se
demande où sont passés ces cahiers de
doléances et si quelqu'un il a eu au
gouvernement on peut en douter
puis ça a été le ségur de l'hôpital
qu'on se rappelle de quoi on parle c'est
un an de grève avant la crise de l'aco
vide avec des personnels soignants qui
demande plus de moyens pour pouvoir
soyez nos concitoyens on revient à la
question de la souveraineté et on se
moquait de madame busin alors ministre
de la santé lever les yeux au ciel et
une arena avait expliqué ces conditions
de travail et ce bobo de ségur de
l'hôpital n'a rien donné
et maintenant eh bien ça va être le lait
convention citoyenne pour pour le climat
écarté la question climatique
bon maintenant c'est vrai que le move au
delà de la sécurité comme l'a dit un
syndicaliste dans votre politique et
dans notre reportage
ça va faire beaucoup de bruit pour rien
et c'est un peu se moquer des français
et en particulier par des policiers
alors la question des violences
policières
elle est au coeur des débats depuis
plusieurs semaines depuis plusieurs mois
selon vous comment est-ce qu'on retisse
ce lien aujourd'hui entre la police et
sa population
mais d'abord il y a moi je sus je pense
qu'il ya des violences de certains
policiers
ceux qui sont ultra violents racistes
doivent être radicalement
poursuivi et je sais déjà cédé effectif
il ya un nettoyage qui doit être fait et
bien évidemment ce n'est pas la grande
majorité des policiers
et puis quand on parle de violences
policières
on pense beaucoup également aux
manifestations en particulier celle des
jets jaune c'est intéressant de le
comparer avec ce qui se passe
actuellement en russie où il ya beaucoup
d'arrestations
faut-il rappeler qu'en france il ya eu
douze mille arrestations pendant le
mouvement des gilets jaunes première
nation plus d'un millier de gilet jaune
qui n'avait jamais eu aucune activité
politique
aucun casier judiciaire qu'elle se sont
retrouvés en prison donc c'est une
répression massive qui s'est fait à coup
de matraque à coups de élevé des coups
de grenades de désencerclement ce sont
des centaines de blessés graves
et bien sûr les ceux qui sont élus clé
qui ont perdu leurs membres mais aussi
des traumatismes cérébraux de guerre
comme l'ont dit certains incertain
certains médecins
eh bien ça ce n'est pas des policiers
qui se réunissent le soir pour taper sur
les français ça c'est une volonté
politique
quand il ya autant d'arrestations et
autant de blessés s'est voulue par le
gouvernement
voulue par emmanuel macron pour casser
un mouvement social qui lui faisait peur
hélas les comptes à rendre ne sont pas
exclusivement par ce qui appuie sur la
gâchette n'est sûr parce qu'ils donnent
qui donne l'ordre
voilà pour les pour les violences pour
les violences policières et je pense que
effectivement comme s'étaient proposés
comme cela était proposé par monsieur
darmanin mais c'était déjà proposé
vienne avant par par d'autres
personnalités politiques je pense
monsieur mélenchon à la france a
soumises en 2010 est d'augmenter la
durée de formation des policiers qui est
bien courte malheureusement en ce moment
tu es s'ils ont effectivement qui sera
au coeur de ce beauvau de la sécurité de
la question de la formation merci à vous
georges kiejman aux fidji d'avoir
accepté notre invitation ce matin sur
rtl france je le rappelle vous êtes
président de république souveraine